[موسيقى]
عندما يتحدث الناس عن مدى ضرر الصودا
بالنسبة لك ، غالبًا ما يستشهدون بهذه الدراسة التي
تابعت ما يقرب من 500000 شخص على مدار 20
عامًا ووجدوا أن الأشخاص الذين
يشربون معظم الصودا لديهم أعلى معدلات
الوفاة من جميع أنواع الأسباب
المختلفة وهذا القطع  تراجع أيضًا حقًا في
مدى احتمالية وفاتك
بهذه الأشياء ، حيث سيشرب الكثير من الناس
عصير الفاكهة بدلاً من الصودا وأعتقد
أن هذا سيكون قرارًا أفضل ولكن
أفضل قليلاً فقط لا
يتعلق الأمر بالسكر فحسب ، بل يتعلق بمدى السرعة
أن السكر يدخل إلى مجرى الدم
إذا أخذت الألياف ، فالوتيرة
التي يدخل بها السكر إلى جسمك
لا تزال مقلقة للغاية ، ومن الصعب
التخلص من كل السكر وأنت بحاجة إلى بعض
السكر ، لكن السكر لا يقتصر فقط على كل شيء موجود
في الخبز  رطب في العديد من
الصلصات التي ليست حتى حلوة ، من
الواضح أنه في الحلويات والكعك والآيس
كريم إذا كان بإمكانك قطع السكر المضاف ،
فمن المحتمل أنك لا تزال
تحصل على أكثر من كافٍ ضع في اعتبارك
بالنسبة لمعظم وجودنا البشري ،
اعتاد البشر الحصول على السكر بضع مرات فقط
في السنة عندما تساقط الثمار من الأشجار
حتى العسل كان يحميها النحل
والآن نأكل ما يقرب من مائة وثلاثين
رطلاً من السكر في السنة ، معظم ذلك
لا يوجد  لا تفعل أي شيء ذي قيمة
لجسمنا باستثناء التسبب في جميع المشاكل
مثل مرض السكري من النوع 2 ، مما يزيد من خطر الإصابة
بأمراض القلب والسكتات الدماغية ، مما يقلل من
السكريات المضافة ، ويمكنك حقًا
تقليل خطر الإصابة بكل هذه الأشياء